thank you
good afternoon we'll have statements by
the Secretary General and the Prime
Minister Secretary General so prime
minister
welcome it's great to see you again
welcome back to the NATO headquarters it
is good to have you here Georgia is one
of NATO's closes partners and the Allies
fully supports Georgia's sovereignty and
the territorial Integrity we continue to
call on Russia to reverse the
recognition of Georgian territories as
independent states
today in our meeting we will talk about
the NATO Georgia partnership and how we
can further strengthen our partnership
in particular through the substantial
NATO Georgia package
I welcome Georgia student Atlantic
aspirations and you can count on NATO's
continued political and practical
support
in turn I count on Georgia to redouble
efforts on domestic reforms and uphold
Democratic standards that is why I
welcomed the decision to withdraw the
draft law on foreign influence which was
incompatible with euro-atlantic values
and the protection of fundamental
freedoms
the Georgian people have made clear that
they want a democratic prosperous
country integrated into the
euro-atlantic region NATO will continue
to be your partner as you work towards
fulfilling these aspirations
today we will also talk about Russia's
war of aggression and the importance of
standing by Ukraine
last week I was in Kiev my message to
president zielinski was clear NATO
stands with Ukraine today and for as
long as it takes we do not know when the
war will end but we know that Russian
aggression is a toxic pattern that must
be stopped once and for all
Georgia and the Georgian people
understand this very well
Ukraine is upholding its right to
self-defense under the U.N Charter and
we expect all NATO Partners to support
this Aim so prime minister welcome once
again I look forward to our discussions
please
thank you very much the Secretary
General
let me first of all thank you for this
opportunity to meet and have a
discussion on the busy agenda of our
bilateral cooperation
especially in today's turbulent security
environment the war in Ukraine which is
a huge challenge for us
for the entire European security
architecture for Georgia for our region
plus Georgia has its own
problem with Russia the ongoing
occupation
so therefore I'm grateful for this
meeting
and I also want to thank you for your
personal dedication and Leadership
throughout the years to make NATO more
united and strong in advance in
advancing cooperation with partners
let me also express our strong
appreciation for Ally support
of Georgia's euro-atlantic aspirations
as well as unwavering support for
Georgia's sovereignty and territory
Integrity within its internationally
recognized borders
as one of the most reliable and capable
partner of the alliance Georgia has a
track record of active participation in
NATO missions and operations in Iraq and
Afghanistan
our strong contribution
to the common euro-atlantic peace and
security is well known
and Georgia's euro-atlantic
aspiration remains
our top
foreign policy priority
I also want to mention that we have
achieved a significant progress during
the last 10 years
we signed the association agreement with
European Union Free Trade Agreement with
European Union
we got the Visa free regime and we last
year we received European perspective
which is a historic decision and now
we're working actively on the
implementation of so-called 12
priorities which will finalize soon and
we are confident that Georgia deserve
deserves uh became the status
and also want to mention
that I was privileged to open
a joint Training Center NATO Georgia
joint Training Center together with you
back in 2015 which is a very
clear example of our successful
Corporation and since then this Center
has been operating
very successful so I also want to thank
you for this
so we stand ready to deepen our
political dialogue and practical
cooperation with nato in all dimensions
once again thank you I look forward to
all the discussion thank you sir
thank you thank you thank you